okay so he's just going to come in there
you go
okay
boom inside here
inside elbow
hit heat
second target start up
[Music]
but i want some more contact here
he's coming in you see that's what he
was doing we can start close
he's coming he's trying to displace him
okay so he came in and i'm going to take
this
and all i'm doing is bracing don't stop
coming in just come in
that's all i'm doing so he comes in
that's all i'm doing so i'm not going
into him
there is this kind of oblique angle here
and when he comes in halfway goes around
me he's that half goes around me
and the other half goes around him so
i'm not going in
and hitting him here he's coming in
hitting him at that oblique end
then he comes in boom hit him at the
oblique angle
then same thing no base there
boom this place
so i'm here boom oblique angle then
in boom
just like he's here and he's going to
hit the ground he's going to hit the
ground
let's just instead of the contact point
here the contact point is here
so he comes he comes in and he hits the
ground
so we're here he comes in he hits the
then same thing hits the ground so
all right i'm here it comes in here
is your body
right there
um
[Music]
right
so use your uh kazushi pattern
angle hold right right there
come back
[Music]
maybe let's go
oh
this one
uh
look at his face he got his face all
jacked up
when he pulled it you see that that's
where my throat is
all i do is another cookie line
so
you see and once i change this angle
that legs in the wrong place
so another pokemon
i
find his center
don't miss his center don't miss his
center over here
find his center
[Music]
hey